[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: This is Katie Cantrell
with Factory Farming Awareness
Coalition.
She's here to speak today
about the impact of animal
agriculture on the environment.
And so I hope everybody
enjoys the presentation.
KATIE CANTRELL:
OK.
SPEAKER 1: So here's Katie.
KATIE CANTRELL:
Thank you so much.
And thank you,
everyone, for coming.
So again, my name
is Katie Cantrell.
I'm the founder and
executive director
of the Factory Farming
Awareness Coalition.
We're a local nonprofit, based
in the Bay Area, dedicated
to talking to people about the
impact of our food choices.
Here's an outline of what
we'll be discussing today.
The basics of factory
farming, what that term
means, an overview of the
environmental impacts,
and we'll conclude by talking
about potential solutions.
So while some of
this information
is disturbing and
depressing, I promise that we
will end on an upbeat note.
And there'll be little
"cuteness interludes"
in between each section to give
you a chance to ask questions.
Now how many of you sang "Old
MacDonald" when you were kids,
or maybe you're singing
it with your own children?
So when we walk
into the supermarket
and look around
pictures on products,
it looks like Old MacDonald's
farm is still around today.
We see all these
rolling green hillsides,
all those happy cows.
But unfortunately, this is not
what farming is like anymore
in the United States.
Rather than old MacDonald,
this is what we have today.
Factory farms are technically
known as Concentrated Animal
Feeding Operations, or CAFOs.
It's a practice of keeping
thousands-- tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands--
of animals in confinement
for their entire lives.
This is done to produce the most
product for the most profit.
Before we go any
further, does anyone
want to guess how many
animals are bred and killed
for food every year
in the United States.
If you don't already
know the answer-- anyone
want to take a guess?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
KATIE CANTRELL: OK, so
pretty close-- so yeah,
there's actually nine billion.
There between nine
and 10 billion animals
raised and killed for
food every single year
in the United States, alone.
This is just land animals,
not even counting fish.
So there are more farmed
animals in the United States
than there are people
on the entire planet.
Now of these nine
billion animals,
what percentage of
them do you think
are raised on
factory farms rather
than on those nice, small,
Old MacDonald type farms?
AUDIENCE: 80%.
KATIE CANTRELL: 80%?
About 99%-- so 99% of
meat that you see nowadays
in restaurants or
supermarkets is
going to be coming from
these factory farms.
Now if we've heard the
term factory farming,
it's usually in the
context of animal welfare.
And that's not what we'll
be focusing on today,
but I do briefly want to
discuss what conditions
look like on factory
farms, because that's also
what contributes to most of
the environmental problems,
as well.
And I think it
helps to understand
the mindset of
factory farming, which
is really summed up best by
"National Hog Farmer Magazine."
They said, "the breeding
sow"-- which is a mother pig--
"should be thought
of and treated
as a valuable piece of
machinery whose function
is to pump out baby pigs
like a sausage machine."
So these are no longer
thought of as living,
sentient creatures.
They're thought of as
units of production.
It is this mindset
that allows us
to treat farmed animals in
ways that we would never dream
of treating our dogs or cats.
So again, the hallmark
of factory farming
is this intensive confinement.
The animals spend their entire
lives, sometimes confined
in cages or crates so small that
they can't even turn around.
Other industries, like
the turkey industry,
they're kept by the thousands
inside of these sheds.
So this, obviously,
causes extreme problems
for animal welfare.
They can't engage in even the
most basic of natural behavior.
But it is also this
overcrowding that
causes the environmental
issues, as well.
So for the rest of
the presentation,
you have to keep
in mind that these
are what conditions look
like on factory farms,
where 99 percent of
meat is coming from.
Now one question that
frequently comes up
is what about the
labels that we see
on products that seem
to indicate they're
coming from better places?
So I want to quickly go
through what those mean.
I'll start with cage-free.
This is a picture of
a cage-free egg farm.
Now, it's true, these
hens aren't in cages,
but it's not exactly what we
imagine when we see the term
cage-free, when we see
those happy-looking chickens
on the front of the carton.
So it really means just that.
They're not in cages,
but they're still
kept by the tens
of thousands inside
of these industrial sheds
for their entire lives.
Unfortunately, conditions
on free-range farms
are very similar.
So technically, it
means the animals
must have "access
to the outdoors,"
but there are no real
enforced specifications
for what that means.
And there are a lot of loopholes
as well, that a lot of farms
get away with, keeping
their animals confined
by the tens of thousands
inside of the sheds.
But if there is "access
to the outdoors,"
like a tiny little door that
opens onto a dirt patch,
it can technically
count as free-range,
even if not a single animal ever
actually steps foot outside.
Now to give you a
real world example,
the wording on the left is from
a package of Judy's Eggs, which
is a popular organic,
free-range brand from right here
in northern California.
It says these hens are
raised in wide open spaces
in Sonoma Valley, where they
are free to roam, scratch,
and play.
Well, on the right, you
can see an aerial photo
of what Judy's Farm
actually looks like.
Those are those industrial
sheds with tens of thousands
of chickens.
There aren't any birds outside.
And the purple that
you see in front there
is a manure pit, which
we'll be talking about much
more in a few minutes.
Now, Judy's actually
settled a lawsuit
with the Animal
Legal Defense Fund
for misleading consumers with
the claims on their packaging.
So they have
changed the wording,
but they're still certified
free-range and organic.
And in fact, they re-brand under
several different brand names,
which is a very common practice
to make consumers think they're
coming from these nice, little,
individual family farms,
when they're coming from the
same source-- these factory
farms.
So they sell under Judy's,
Uncle Eddy's, Rock Island,
Gold Circle.
They're also a leading
supplier for Whole Foods 365
brand and Organic Valley.
So unfortunately, even
some of the most respected
organic, free-range
brands are, in fact,
sourcing from factory farms.
The final term that you
might see is 'humane,
and this has no legal
meaning whatsoever.
The USDA does not regulate
the term 'humane,' nor do they
regulate the term 'natural,'
so any company can put these
on any product.
It's really just a
marketing gimmick.
And it's unfortunate
because these companies
are taking advantage
of consumers' desire
to buy products that are
coming from a better place.
We don't want animals
to be mistreated.
We don't want to impact the
environment in negative ways.
But unfortunately,
this is usually
just used as a mechanism
to increase the price
when they're still coming
from factory farms.
Animal agriculture is one of
the single most destructive
industries on the planet.
I know this can seem a
little bizarre if we're still
imagining Old McDonald's farm.
What could be so bad
about Old McDonald, right?
So I'm going to
walk you through it.
So again, keep in
mind that there
are nine billion animals raised
and killed for food every year.
And this is where most of
the environmental problems
stem from-- it's the sheer
number of animals that
are required to make enough meat
for 300 million plus Americans
to eat meat every single
day, often with every meal.
And the problems
come from the fact
that these are nine billion
living, breathing, eating,
pooping animals.
Now, they're eating
primarily corn and soy.
When we imagine farmers
and farmland in the US,
we, I think, imagine growing
crops to feed to people, right?
But in the United States,
over half of all farmland
is planted with corn and
soy, and most of that
is going to feed not people,
but to animals on factory farms.
This is a problem for
several different reasons.
One is that animals are actually
a very inefficient source
of food.
So imagine that you are
raising an animal for food.
From the day that
that animal is born,
till the day that you slaughter
it, you have to feed it, right?
So that's days, weeks, months,
potentially even years,
that you're giving this
animal food every single day.
So if you add up all
the food that you
give to that animal over
the course of its lifetime,
it ends up being anywhere
from 2 to 15 times more
food than the amount of food you
get from eating that animal's
flesh.
The latest studies have found
that if we cut global meat
consumption in
half, and we use all
that farmland to grow fruits
and veggies for people
to eat directly,
rather than growing
that corn and soy to feed
to animals on factory farms,
we could feed
every single person
on earth today, plus an
extra two billion people.
So we hear a lot of
talk about how are we
going to feed the growing
global population?
And in fact, we
could do it easily
if we were using our
land more efficiently,
but eating lower
on the food chain.
This land use is a huge
problem globally, as well.
Meat production is actually
the leading cause of the Amazon
rain forest being cut down.
We can see that here in this
infographic from the Center
for Biological Diversity.
Every minute, there are
two acres of rain forest
clear cut to make grazing
land for beef cattle
or land to grow
corn and soy to feed
to animals on factory farms.
This is also a problem in
the United States, as well.
Oftentimes, people think I don't
want to support factory farms,
so I'm going to buy
free-range beef.
Now there are a couple of
different problems with this.
One is that actually,
most beef cattle
are free-range for the first
8 to 10 months of their lives.
So if you drive--
especially in Marin,
Petaluma, that area--
you might see these
bucolic-looking cattle
grazing on hillsides,
and it looks very nice.
But most of those
cattle are then
shipped to industrial
feedlots, where they're
fed corn and soy intensively
for the last few months
of their lives to fatten them
up to reach market weight.
The other big problem
is that while there
are certain ecosystems
that do benefit
from having grazing
ruminant animals,
there is a limit
to how many animals
that land can sustain-- it's
called a carrying capacity.
And when you exceed
that, you start
to have these very serious
ecological problems,
and that's what we're
seeing across the West, now.
So cattle are being
grazed on public land,
so the government is basically,
subsidizing this grass in order
to graze these
free-range cattle,
but the Bureau of
Land Management,
which manages this
land, is not ensuring
that it's being managed
properly to prevent
these environmental problems.
So you have too many
cattle on this land,
so they're eating
everything that
comes up out of the ground.
They're eating what would
grow into shrubs and trees
to provide habitat
for native animals,
this also causes soil
erosion, impacts waterways--
so a lot of different
devastating impacts
of overgrazing.
And to make matters worse, there
is a very secretive government
agency called Wildlife Services.
They're a part of the USDA.
And in 2015, they killed
over three million animals,
mostly at the
request of ranchers.
So they're killing off predators
like wolves, bears, coyotes,
foxes, mountain lions that
could kill the livestock.
They're killing off prairie
dogs and ground squirrels that
could dig holes that the
cattle could fall into,
even rounding up and
killing buffalo--
so native ruminant animals,
because they're competing
with the cattle for feed.
So we're destroying these
entire native ecosystems
in order to make them suitable
for free-range cattle.
Now another big problem
with all of these animals
and all of these crops is that
they're very water intensive.
Now when we think about
ways to save water,
what are some things
that come to mind?
What are ways we're told
we can help save water?
AUDIENCE: Less
water in the shower.
KATIE CANTRELL: Yeah,
take shorter showers,
right-- that's a classic one.
Turn off the tap when you
brush your teeth, right?
Water your lawn less.
So all of these suggestions
focus on our direct water
usage.
In this next video clip
from the movie "Cowspiracy,"
we'll see how this compares to
the water impact of our food
choices.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I found out that
one quarter pound
hamburger requires over 660
gallons of water to produce.
Here I've been taking short
showers trying to save water,
and to find out just eating
one hamburger is the equivalent
of showering two entire months.
So much attention is given to
lowering our home water use,
yet domestic water
use is only 5%
of what is consumed
in the US, versus
55% for animal agriculture.
That's because it takes upwards
of 2,500 gallons of water
to produce one pound of beef.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KATIE CANTRELL:
The single best way
that we can help save
water on a daily basis
is through our food choices.
So the numbers they use
there are on the high end,
but even the more
conservative estimates show
that switching from a hamburger
to a veggie burger, just one
single time opting for a veggie
burger instead of a hamburger,
you save as much water as not
showering for one entire month.
So all that water, all of
this corn and soy, also
a lot of hormones,
pesticides, antibiotics--
are fed to these
nine billion animals.
It goes through their
system and then what happens
to food after we digest it?
It comes out as poop.
Farm animals in
the United States
produce 130 times as much
poop as the entire US
human population.
And there is very little
waste infrastructure
for factory farms.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [WHISPERS] Follow me.
One of America's biggest secrets
is that farms practically
don't exist anymore.
The animals we eat are grown
inside giant hidden factories.
Since 2012, I've been
secretly planning a project
to expose these factory farms
using the highest tech spy
equipment available--
drones.
This video provides
just a sample
of what I saw during only
a few days of filming.
[BUZZING]
You're looking at a
lake of toxic feces
and urine, the size of
four football fields.
That's because thousands
upon thousands of pigs
are inside of these buildings.
Their waste falls through
slats in the concrete floor
and it's flushed directly into
this giant open-air cesspool.
How many of these kinds
of factories are there?
In North Carolina alone,
there are over 2,000
and the consequences
are disastrous.
- The waste falls
through the floors.
It's flushed out into an
open pit, like a cesspool.
It's easy for a
big hog operation
to have as much waste
as a medium-sized city.
Of course, the pit will fill
up, so it has to be emptied,
and they're emptied by
spraying the liquid waste.
- Yes, you heard that right.
- If you're familiar
with a garden sprayer,
they are gigantic
versions of that.
So they're making
droplets, fine mists,
out of this liquid waste,
and that can drift down wind
into the neighboring
communities.
- I shut my hog operation
down and I got out of it.
And I couldn't--
I just couldn't do
another person that way,
to make them smell that.
It is a cesspool that you
put feces and urine in,
a hole in the ground that
you dump toxic waste in.
And I've seen dead hogs in
them, and stuff like that.
- People can't open their
windows, they can't go outside.
- I've seen it.
I've talked to the people.
I've seen the little children.
They say, mom and daddy, why
we got to smell this stuff?
You get stories like, I
can't hang my clothes out.
Feces and urine odor comes
by and attaches itself it
to your clothes.
And then people
are saying, we're
scared to invite neighbors.
- It can, I think, very
correctly be called
environmental racism or
environmental injustice--
that people of color,
low income people,
bear the brunt of
these practices.
- This is where they
spray animal waste on us.
This is about eight feet
from my mother's house.
- What is it like
when the mist--
- It's like you
think it's raining.
- Really?
- You think it's raining.
We don't open the
doors or the windows,
but the odor still comes in.
It takes your breath away.
Then you start gagging,
you get headaches.
- There are a number of studies
of asthma and asthma symptoms,
particularly in children,
near these facilities.
Among adults, there are
reports of several types
of upper respiratory symptoms.
These pollutants are affecting
people's blood pressure.
- Who's responsible
for all this?
Smithfield Foods,
specifically, the subdivision
Murphy Brown, which
controls the factory
farms shown in all of the
drone footage in this video.
Smithfield is by far,
the largest pork producer
in the entire world.
And inside these
buildings, there
is something else entirely.
- Pigs are really
intelligent animals.
They are more
intelligent than dogs,
they are more
intelligent than cats.
In the average pig
barn, there could
be hundreds, if not thousands,
of pigs crammed into this
one sprawling indoor space.
Their entire life is spent
standing on concrete floors.
Mother pigs are locked in
metal cages so small that they
literally cannot even turn
around for months at a time.
- This is not a partisan issue.
We are all opposed to
children being made sick,
to animals being abused, and to
everyday people's lives being
ruined by the stench of
cesspools in their backyards.
These thousands of
lakes of toxic waste
must be among the most
bizarre and disturbing
environmental phenomenon that
have ever confronted America.
And they've been
kept well-hidden
from the public for long enough.
[BUZZING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KATIE CANTRELL: So
you've just seen
what happens to all
of this waste-- it's
fairly shocking, right?
And for urban consumers, meat
starts at the supermarket,
it starts at a restaurant.
We don't ever have
to see or experience
the real impacts of it.
So it's usually these rural,
low-income communities,
often communities
of color, that bear
the brunt of the rest
of our meat consumption.
They're the ones who
have to be exposed
to this environmental
pollution on a daily basis.
The other huge problem
with all of these animals
and all of this waste
is climate change.
A report from the United Nations
found that animal agriculture
creates more greenhouse gas
emissions than all the planes,
trains, and cars in the entire
world all added up together.
Part of the reason for this is
that ruminant animals like cows
and sheep, lambs--
actually burp methane,
which is 20 times worse
for climate change
than carbon dioxide.
The poop from all of these
different types of animals--
chickens, pigs, all the
ones that we've seen--
releases nitrous oxide,
which is 300 times worse
for climate change
than carbon dioxide.
And there are also all of the
impacts of that deforestation.
When you consider the whole
lifecycle of everything that's
required to produce the
meat, the deforestation
also plays a large
role because they're
cutting down forests that would
otherwise be absorbing CO2.
So when you factor in all
of these things together,
you see that our food choices
are also the single best way
that we can help
shrink our carbon
footprint on a daily basis,
just like our water footprint.
So one study found that not
eating meat just one day a week
saves some more greenhouse
gas emissions than buying
local food 100% of the time.
A different study found that if
everyone in the United States
ate no meat or cheese
just one day a week,
it would be like not
driving 91 billion miles,
or taking 7.6 million
cars off the road.
So we can think about, what
are the chances that we're
going to convince seven million
people to sell their cars
and never drive again--
probably not going
to happen, right?
Whereas getting people to not
eat meat just one day a week--
choosing a PB&J instead
of a turkey sandwich
and a veggie burrito
instead of a beef burrito--
it's one of the easiest
and most effective ways
that we can help
stop climate change.
And in fact, there's more
and more scientific evidence
showing that we cannot keep
climate change to a level
that's conducive to human
civilization without addressing
the carbon footprint
of agriculture.
So this study found that the
agriculture-related emissions
alone, if we continue
our current practices,
especially as the
global population grows
and demand for meat
goes up worldwide,
then agriculture alone
will take up almost all
of the global carbon
budget by 2050.
So this means that even if we
got every other industry down
to carbon neutral, but we
left agriculture the same,
we would still be hitting
that two-degree target.
So the only scenario that
would reduce emissions in 2050
compared to 2009 levels is
what they call the healthy diet
scenario, which is switching
to significantly more
plant-based protein.
And as an added benefit,
eating more plant-based protein
also has positive impacts
on the health of citizens
and on health care costs.
So if Americans transition
to a plant-based diet,
not only would it reduce
food-related greenhouse gas
emissions by 79%, we could
also avoid 460,000 deaths
and save $289 billion in health
care costs and climate change
costs.
So one of the reasons that
people eat so much meat
is that it seems
cheap, but that's
because the true costs
of it are externalized.
So we don't have to see the
environmental costs, the health
care costs, when
we go to the store,
when we go to the restaurant.
But as taxpayers, we are
actually paying the true cost.
And the most effective
way to reverse that
is to transition to a
more plant-based diet.
The basic solution
is very simple.
We have to eat less meat--
that's really what
it boils down to.
And different organizations,
world leaders,
are starting to catch
on to this and starting
to encourage people to switch
to plant-based protein.
So the United Nations
Environmental Program
has urged first world
citizens to cut our meat
consumption in half, become
what they call "demitarians."
The Stockholm International
Water Institute
has gone even further
and said that we
need to limit animal-based
foods to just 5%
of our total daily calories.
Right now, they
make up about 30%
of the standard American diet.
So they said we need to
eat just 1/6 as much meat
as we currently are.
And they've warned that
if we do not do this,
then we will be faced with
food and water shortages
worldwide that could
lead to civil war.
So the stakes are
about as high as they
get when we're
talking about things
like climate change,
global famine,
and all this can be
impacted directly
through our food choices.
Now a big challenge is
how do you get people
interested in eating less meat?
There are a lot of reasons
that people eat meat--
it tastes good, it's
cheap, it's convenient,
it's part of our culture,
it's part of our habit.
And so now, different
organizations,
nonprofits, as well as many
different food start-ups,
especially in the Bay
Area, are working on ways
to get people
excited about eating
more plant-based protein.
One initiative that's been very
successful is Meatless Mondays.
This was actually started
by Johns Hopkins University
as a public health initiative.
As we saw a few slides
ago, health care costs
are hugely impacted by the
amount of animal protein
that Americans
currently consume.
Many of the leading causes of
death-- cancer, heart disease,
diabetes, stroke--
are directly related to eating
too much animal protein.
So they figured if people
eat even 1/7 less meat--
if people are not eating
meat one day a week--
then it will really
help people's health.
And many other organizations
have jumped on board
and said it's a great way
to help the environment
and animals, as well.
And even for
die-hard meat lovers,
the idea of not eating
meat just one day a week
is something that
seems very doable.
And currently, a
third of Americans
report trying to participate.
Green Monday is also another
really successful program
that is similar to Meatless
Monday, but really focused
on those environmental
impacts, emphasizing the fact
that the best way to
go green is by eating
more plant-based protein.
It's actually
based in Hong Kong,
and they've had
tremendous success
in shifting the entire
city's eating habits
by having a really positive,
empowering campaign,
emphasizing that eating
green, choosing veg options,
is a very effective
step to take.
And Green Monday emphasizes that
it's not a one-size-fits-all.
So oftentimes, people are
deterred from taking a step
because they think
that they won't
be able to be perfectly
100% vegetarian or vegan,
and so people get
dissuaded and they give up.
But as a Green
Monday shows, there
are a number of different ways
that we can go about this.
So whether that's routine-based,
one day a week-- so
Green Monday or Meatless Monday.
You can do every day for lunch.
Eat a vegetarian
or vegan lunch--
just one meal a day, it's
pretty doable for most people.
But if you do that,
then a third of the time
you'll be eating veg.
It can also be portion-based,
so decreasing the amount of meat
they're eating, increasing the
amount of plant-based protein,
vegetarian foods on your plate.
Or it can be impact-based,
so pledging to only order
veggie burgers instead of
hamburgers from now on.
There are many different
ways that we can play around
with our food
choices and increase
the amount of plant-based
foods that we're eating.
And it, again, is one of the
single most effective actions
that we can take.
There are also some very
exciting tech solutions
that are in the works right
now, namely, clean meat.
So clean meat involves
extracting stem cells
from animal tissue, culturing
those, and then, basically,
growing meat tissue in the lab.
And then layering that to
produce hamburgers, chicken
nuggets.
So it is actually meat.
I mean, it is animal
tissue and it's
based on medical technology
used to grow human skin cells
to graph on to burn victims.
But they're actually
growing meat.
And this is successful.
Memphis Meats has produced--
I think just about a month ago--
they had the first tastings of
clean chicken and duck meat.
And there are a few
other companies that
are working on beef, as well.
And this is extremely more
efficient than factory farming.
So clean meat uses
99% less land,
produces 96% less
greenhouse gas emissions,
and uses 96% less water.
And there's a really
great organization
called the Good
Food Institute that
is working to help encourage
the science behind clean meat
and policy around
clean meat, as well.
So according to
latest estimates,
it should be on the
market within about four
to five years.
Again, the technology
is there, it's
just a matter of
scaling it so that it's
cost-competitive with
factory farm meat.
But I think this is one of
the most hopeful developments.
If we can replace fast
food meat with clean meat,
then we will see drastic
impacts on the environment,
and obviously, for
animals, as well.
But the good news
is that you don't
have to wait four or five
years to make a difference.
There are a number
of other start-ups,
all based right around
here, that are working
on creating foods that have
the same taste textures that we
love, but they are made
from more sustainable
plant-based sources.
So as Biz Stone
said, "these guys
are coming at the meat analog
industry not as a novelty.
They're coming at it from
the big science angle."
These products are not made for
vegetarian markets, anymore,
they're not made
for a niche market.
They're getting the top
chefs, top food scientists,
to create products that
are really delicious
and satisfying for
die-hard meat lovers.
So you have companies like
Beyond Meat, Impossible
Foods, which makes the burger--
"the burger that
bleeds," as it's
been getting a lot of
attention in the press--
Hampton Creek Foods, which
makes Just Mayo, cookies,
salad dressings, and all
of these products you
can read articles,
see interviews online.
They do blind taste
tests and people
can't tell the difference.
So if the main reason
that we're eating meat
is because it tastes
good, it's fantastic
news that there are
now products available
that have that same
taste, the same texture,
but they're better for
us, better for animals,
better for the environment,
so it's really a win-win.
And this is a top-growing trend.
This is really the direction
that the market is moving.
So "Food Navigator Magazine,"
Mintel, "The Nutrition Business
Journal"--
I mean, they've all
documented that Americans
are eating more and
more plant-based foods,
they're interested in
it from a health angle,
from an environmental angle,
and this is consistently
one of the fastest growing
sectors of the food system.
As a result, an even
more exciting trend,
is that meat and dairy
companies are actually
starting to jump on board.
So even Tyson Chicken-- their
CEO, the CEO of Tyson Chicken--
said the plant-based protein
is the way of the future.
And dairy companies are also
investing in plant-based dairy.
So Dannon Yogurt, the parent
company that makes Dannon,
bought White Wave, which makes
Silk soy milk and almond milk.
And they're shifting a lot
of their marketing budget
away from marketing dairy
foods towards marketing
plant-based foods.
So we see this very
positive feedback cycle,
where the more that we
vote with our dollars
and we buy these products,
the more appealing
that food sector becomes to
businesses, they invest in it.
Then those products are
more widely available,
they're cheaper, they're
more accessible, and so more
and more people
start buying them.
And as we've seen, especially
with products like almond milk,
then they start to take up a
larger and larger market share,
and as a result, there are
fewer animals bred and killed
for food every year.
So often times, people say,
but I'm just one person.
What difference do my
food choices really make?
But we really can have a very
direct impact on this industry.
And especially at a
time when federal policy
is increasingly
frustrating and alarming--
there's zero chance of federal
action on climate change
within these next few years--
so this is even more
important, that we can really
directly impact this
industry, and have
a real impact on climate change
through our daily food choices.
And it's really never been
easier or at least tastier
to eat these plant-based foods.
So Gardien products are
probably my favorite.
They have these
great, crispy tenders.
And they're actually
owned by the company
that makes Hungry Man dinners.
So again, we see
these meat companies
starting to invest in
plant-based products.
Almond milk is available
at every supermarket.
Ben and Jerry's now
has seven flavors
of almond milk-based ice cream.
So we see, again, it's
a growing trend, which
is great for all of us because
it makes it so easy to do.
And again, you don't have
to be 100% vegetarian
to order a veggie burger
or a veggie burrito.
You don't have to be
totally vegan all the time
to put almond milk in your
cereal instead of cow milk.
It's not about being
all-or-nothing, 100% perfect.
It's about looking at the
impacts of our food choices
and deciding what we want
our money to support.
And the other good news is
that, again, this really
has a direct impact.
So supply and demand applies,
demand has been going down--
since 2007, demand has dropped.
And as a result,
there are 400 million
fewer animals bred
and killed for food
now than there
were back in 2007,
as a direct result of people
like you and me deciding
to eat less meat.
So remember that every time
you decide not to eat an animal
product, you are taking
action against one
of the most destructive
industries on the planet.
We'd love to get your feedback
on the presentation, so just
a quick survey.
And if you'd like to sign
up for our mailing list,
we send out just once a month
newsletter with recipes,
national news about factory
farming, petitions to sign,
things like that.
And while also sending
you some recipes
and some further resources,
but you can also fill this out
anonymously.
So is there-- the
question was is there
a good place to find the sources
for the studies that I cited,
and more information.
Yeah, so we have all of the
citations for our presentation
available on our website.
And we actually have
a-- and unfortunately, I
don't have any with
me today-- but we
have a new leaflet
that's focused
on the environmental impacts.
And there's a page
with citations for that
also available on our web site.
So those have all of
the original studies
that we're citing from.
The movie "Cowspiracy"
is also a good resource.
And they have a website
with a lot of information,
as well, specifically about
the environmental studies.
For more information about
food sources and what to eat,
nutrition, all
that-- chooseveg.com
is a really fantastic resource.
They've got meal plans,
tips for eating out,
all the nutritional
info that you need.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
KATIE CANTRELL:
So the question is
what's the relationship between
the animal products consumed
in the US and what is
consumed around the world?
So, I mean, it's a pretty
complicated relationship.
It depends on the industry,
but roughly 15% of products
here are exported.
So Americans do hav-- now we
have the second highest meat
consumption in the world.
We were actually
passed by Australia.
But we do eat most of
those products here.
Some of it is exported.
We do import some
products, as well.
And a lot of these
companies are now--
they started in
the United States,
but they're now
multinational corporations.
And actually, Smithfield, which
is the largest pork producer,
was bought, basically--
a majority stake--
was bought by a Chinese company.
And so now, we are starting to
see an increase in pork exports
to China.
So now Americans
are having to deal
with the environmental
pollution,
and these products are exported.
Another huge issue
is alfalfa feed.
Alfalfa is the most intensive
crop, in terms of water.
And Saudi Arabia and
other countries are now--
they're importing alfalfa
from the United States.
So they're basically
importing water.
So this is a huge problem,
because a lot of that alfalfa
is grown in Southern
California and Arizona,
and parts of the country that
are facing these droughts.
And our water is actually being
exported to support the dairy
industry in the Middle East.
And the US is also--
we have set this example
that if you're well-off,
the lifestyle that we've--
that other people want to
emulate as their income grows,
is that meat is an
integral part of living.
Well, eating meat
every day shows
that you are middle
class or upper class.
And so there's a
cultural impact, as well.
And I'm hopeful
that we can change
that, if we can show the United
States is saying, actually,
now plant-based protein
is the way to go.
This is the really
exciting way of the future.
Then, hopefully, countries
that are starting
to ramp up their
meat production will
shift to plant these
protein, as well.
I also have some resources here
for you that we can pass out.
So this is a guide to
cruelty-free eating.
It's got some great
recipes, nutritional info.
And then if we have any
athletes in the room,
this is "The
Compassionate Athlete."
So there's this idea that eating
veg is feminine or it's hard
to get enough protein,
but this is David Carter,
they call him 'the
300-pound vegan.'
He was an NFL
player, he actually
played for the Raiders.
And he's totally vegan, so
good info in there, as well.
Again, we're the Factory
Farming Awareness Coalition,
this is our web site.
And we give presentations,
this is really what we do.
We're focused on
grassroots education.
So if you know of any other
schools, community groups,
businesses, faith
communities, that
might be interested in
learning more about this issue,
we're always happy to come
out and speak for free.
All right, thank you.
SPEAKER: Great.
Thanks, everybody,
for attending.